all right welcome everybody there's just
too much to talk about to waste any time
with
absolutely hilarious and uplifting songs
but i do have a couple of new songs that
i'll play for you guys a little bit
later but we are waiting
about 25 minutes away from a um an event
with joe biden and house democrats
presumably focused around covet stimulus
now over the last hour there's been news
on covet stimulus
if you or someone who is hoping to get
a check from the government in the 1.9
trillion dollar
covid stimulus package there is news
which is that if you make between eighty
and a hundred thousand dollars a year
and i know many of you do
because we've polled our audience and we
have a sort of demographic sense of the
audience
if you make between eighty and a hundred
thousand you might have been hoping
for a check but you're not going to get
one the new
version of the bill is um
making more strict the version that the
senate is moving forward with
is making more strict the income
guidelines
for the fourteen hundred dollar checks
which were going to be two thousand but
now they're 1400 and they were going out
right away but now they're not and it
was going to include the 15
minimum wage but now it isn't that one
it was going to start phasing out uh it
was going to go to zero previously
at a hundred thousand dollars now it
will be fully phased out
at eighty thousand dollars okay
so i mean listen what's crazy is you
might say oh
well david now that they've negotiated
i'm sure republicans will vote for it
right no these were negotiations between
biden and democrats
[Laughter]
it's so pathetic but listen the reality
is
these moderate democrats have power joe
manchin
and jeanne shaheen are in because
democrats in west virginia probably
wouldn't vote for a bernie
jean shaheen new hampshire okay well i
don't know but in any case
we they're sort of like i i wish it
weren't this way
but in a sense this is just the way it
is so what else can we do
this is do we want it passed or not the
good
news about the phase out happening at
80k 160k
for couples is that um
it'll still it'll still help 86 percent
of americans
okay and there's a lot of other
important stuff in there
money for opening school safely money
for vaccinations
things we obviously need um but
it is depressing i mean i'm not going to
pretend it's not depressing we were
going to get two thousand dollar checks
right away with a fifteen dollar minimum
wage even though we knew that that was
just the starting point
and now we're going to get 14 1400
dollar checks
if you make under 80 grand with no 15
minimum wage
we we've got to get it passed it's it's
got to get past i'm not going to pretend
i like it
pepe xanadu asks if i've lost friends
due to becoming trumpists
no no i don't think so can't think of
anybody
that because they're trumpists i don't
talk to them anymore
uh no i can't i can't think of anybody
good question though good question okay
so
that's that's what's going on we're
standing by for joe biden and democrats
and we're going to um hear from them
momentarily i have new callers to
introduce to you
i have songs i have unban requests i
have clips
let's quickly do oh oh oh
this is interesting i think this makes
sense i tweeted that it made sense and
some people
sent me tweets saying no it's bad uh
tomorrow we are expecting
new guidelines from the cdc about what
is safe
for vaccinated people the cdc will
recommend that fully inoculated people
limit social interactions to small group
gatherings
but that it is safe to gather if you are
vaccinated
with other vaccinated people indoors now
this is sort of a double-edged sword
because the people who listen to the cdc
want the vaccine a lot of the people who
don't want the vaccine
aren't listening to the cdc anyway so
the idea of this is like you know
there's been a bunch of people
complaining like why would i get
vaccinated nothing can change you got to
keep wearing a mask you can't do
anything differently
well now the cdc is saying here's we
believe it's safe for vaccinated people
to hang out indoors
without masks and you might think oh
people will now say
now i want the vaccine those people
probably aren't listening to the cdc
anyway if you currently today don't want
a vaccine
you probably don't care what the cdc
says
so i'm i'm sort of unclear but uh as it
says here
cdc ready to release guidance on safe
activities for vaccinated people
recommendations will be the first time
the government has signaled to americans
they can start taking steps to return to
the old
work school and play buh-buh-buh-buh-buh
could be released as early as thursday
will include recommendations to limit
gatherings in the home with vaccinated
individuals to small groups
keep wearing masks in public and do
everything else that people are asking
you to do
agencies advice likely to disappoint
many who hope the increased pace of
inoculations would allow
some common restrictions to be relaxed
immediately for vaccinated people
um i i i think that this makes sense
i think that listen all along i've been
speaking to doctors who are friends of
mine and they've said
obviously at the big picture level
nobody's going to say
if you're vaccinated go have a party but
the truth is
that given how effective these vaccines
are
just normal normal intelligence adults
would know
that if everybody's vaccinated and it's
a small group
the the odds of spread are very low and
you you can hang out without wearing
masks so i think that that's just
logical to say
most people are already thinking it most
people have come to that realization
and the cdc expected as soon as tomorrow
to make that announcement savage
sweetheart says can you explain to me
why democrats are against the minimum
wage this will hurt future democratic
voter turnout
democrats aren't against the minimum
wage some republicans are
there are some democrats who don't want
a 15
minimum wage and they tend not to want
it they claim not to want
it because they are from states with
lower cost of living and lower minimum
wage
that they claim would be more impacted
by the increase
we can infer that it's because their co
corporate donors don't want a 15
minimum wage important uh clarification
okay so we've gotten that out of the way
as far as cases go
it looks like the the temporary plateau
is continuing on down here we got down
to 70k a day and then it sort of popped
up for a couple days to 71.
it's now down to 66 000 cases a day
that's the lowest cases have been on
average
since what what's the date since around
october 23rd 24th
so that's good um
and then as far as deaths go there was
also a little pop and looks like those
are continuing on down
still insane numbers 1933 a day
but that's the lowest since about
december 2nd december 3rd
all right i have heard about the sexual
harassment allegations against madison
cawthorne
and i spoke about them today on the show
uh in terms of where we are with
toontoon yeah we can check it out
i recommended this channel the other day
people are absolutely loving it
the toontoon channel which on sunday had
200 subscribers now has 6600
by my request we now have the
tom yum video with a shout out to the
david pakman show audience
my phone has been vibrating with
notifications from the
strong vibrations the david pakman show
community
you guys are so awesome and i'm so
thankful
and humbled david i can't thank you
enough
if you're new to my channel okay so
anyway things going really really well
with toontune
and uh we expect we expect the videos to
continue
all right so that's cases and deaths and
then we can look at vaccination numbers
really good days over the weekend a bit
of a dip yesterday
1.66 million doses injected yesterday
i'm sorry the day before yesterday 1.73
doses
yesterday i believe we will soon be
regularly at 2.5 million we are already
at 1.94 million doses per day
biden promised a million and a million a
day for a hundred days
i think we might get significantly past
that
significantly past that other super
chats
david i've had shingles for a week and
without you your content and live
streams and my big box of coding
i'd have been lost thank you oh thanks
lori sorry to hear that but glad i can
provide
some help zach wants to know my thoughts
on the mask mandate lift in texas yeah
i've got a long segment about it on
today's podcast
soon to be published to youtube so with
with total respect i'm going to skip
over that now since i did record
something on that earlier
david can you explain the amendment with
bernie in the 15 minimum wage
does the amendment need 60 votes i i
don't i don't know i'm gonna have to
look into that
i don't want to just speak uh
off the cuff should the uk abolish the
monarchy
dump cake i am against the monarchy
chakaseki says should we believe cuomo's
teary-eyed
pseudo-apology or does it mean the dam
is about to burst with further
allegations
probably more allegations coming and i
uh and i'm unsure i i don't i haven't
seen the apology yet
i haven't seen the apology so i'll have
to wait and take a look all right let's
get let me introduce some new character
actually i'll do an unban request
first i do want to say thanks to the
four people who just grabbed
twitch subscriptions i very much
appreciate that that puts us at four
i also want to say thanks to some new
website members
oh no i have no new website members to
thank sadly
that's embarrassing that's embarrassing
okay we have an unban request
i am unable to do these on youtube
because youtube has no such function
twitch makes it very easy to request
being unbanned if you've been banned i
now have a gavel which i use
to make my decisions official
user who goes by the name rich
k kona savage has been
banned and wants to be unbanned
okay their messages include
uh let's see here oh this is interesting
they were banned yesterday
for saying is this sarcastic monkey
not tired of lying they were banned
that's borderline to me i mean i don't
know
that might be more of a time out but
their unban request
says feels good man get wrecked n word
if you're using the n-word when you want
to be unbanned
that is hereby denied and this court has
ruled
and that has been made a permanent ban
and that's the only one i have for today
okay very good so we can uh we can move
on
beyond that
sometimes you say theirs instead of
there are you know what mike you're
right
um in colloquial american english
sometimes the contraction theirs
for there is is used when without a
contraction you would say
there are that that's right
i think you're probably correct that
strictly speaking it's grammatically
incorrect because theirs
implies there is when there are might be
correct
but it is a colloquialism that is
uh i i would argue acceptable all right
thanks to h-a-u-p-t for raining
raiding us on twitch welcome everybody
we're standing by
for joe biden momentarily ryan says
given the b117 variant avoids
some vaccine antibodies and others are
problematic do you think vaccinated
people should relax their standards for
covet well i'm going to go by what the
cdc says
the cdc seems ready to make some
relaxation b117
is well handled by the uh by the current
vaccines
um the the question mark right now is
the south african
variant however the vaccines are still
extraordinarily effective at preventing
serious covet even when the south
african variant is in play
and um still providing pretty good
efficacy instead
in terms of preventing infection as well
so i think it's something to be cautious
about but i don't think we have to go
crazy
uh right now all right william says i'm
less worried about people lying to
businesses than to their loved ones that
they got vaccinated
oh the cdc guidelines aren't about
businesses the the cdc guidelines where
the cdc tomorrow is likely to say
vaccinated people can gather
indoors without masks it's it's for
people making individual decisions it's
not that you can go to
stores without masks that will continue
to depend on store policy
so if people were confused about that i
i apologize
not what it is about okay
um i have something really funny if you
guys remember
that really disastrous um national
national guard national anthem
performance at cpac on saturday
this is really funny a pianist named
brandon etheridge did a video where he
plays along to the anthem
and this makes the completely wild pitch
changes really really evident
and i absolutely love this take a look
at this
[Applause]
this is the best
[Music]
there it is perfect transitions between
all these different keys
it that is just so good
[Music]
[Music]
that's the best one right there
[Music]
the piano really shows you how wild it
is
this should be part of they should be
studying this in college
music programs quite frankly it has to
be studied
[Music]
this is illegal in certain states
actually yeah in the dakotas this you
could be jailed for
[Music]
the this and coming back in as if it's a
completely different song is perfect
[Music]
so that is the national anthem by cpac
girl
in f f sharp g and g
sharp accompaniment oh sorry
accompaniment there by brandon etheridge
really really nicely done i mean that is
that is musical sat
i don't i'm not really that into
gimmicky musical satire in general
but that is like really really really
really good
i do want to say thank you to elijah
serrano elijah just signed up at
joinpackman.com and his new member
number five
today we do have this membership thing
i don't know but it would be great to
get some folks signing up there
every one of you will get a thank you
from me most of the thank yous will be
sincere
most okay all right
um why plagiarize
other youtuber video titles blatant what
is wilma talking about
why plagiarize other youtubers video
titles
i don't know what that's about your
reaction to the anthem makes me so happy
thanks emma glad to provide some
entertainment
githika says this is for the gavel and
also to request you don't play the
national her singing the anthem again
thanks for the even keeled commentary
thanks
pepe says can usa be a world power with
trillions in debt
yes yes jacob says i'm crying
over the uh national anthem yeah no
that's it's it's something else it's
really something else
excuse me uh-oh
almost having a fox news moment there
no i'm just kidding uh i have some new
uh songs i have two new actually is it
two it might just be one
oh wait a second no i have one new song
from dj
physic of the national this is just the
last national anthem material
this is called national anathema
this is a remix
[Music]
no this is brilliant you know what this
is
during the national anthem i said that
it reminded me of this
[Laughter]
okay this is a remix of the national
anthem with
yoko ono samples added
[Applause]
for the land
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
my
national anathema by dj
physic really really nicely done and
integrating the yoko ono samples is good
also one new submission for
this voicemail caller remember this one
this is the source of many memes and
songs
we don't have a nickname for this guy
yet i'll tell you one thing
boy trump is more man
than you'll ever be trump is more
american
than you'll ever be trump
has got more money than you'll ever have
okay so i have a new submission on that
one which is really really good
this one is from vape error
vape error take a listen to this one
thing boys
trump is more man than you'll ever be
i'll tell you one thing boy
trump is more american than you'll ever
be
i'll tell you one thing
you know what would be good
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i like that that could be added
[Music]
okay all right so now i'm fully caught
up i've played everybody's songs
that have been um sent to me
okay uh i didn't compose that by the way
just so people know all right um
shatter the earth says i'm pissing
myself laughing at the mashup with yoko
ono
while trying to listen to this meeting
why ban the word pork makes libs look
weak
is this what hell sounds like david are
you still in a subscription war with sam
cedar i'm not aware that i ever was
i don't know our voicemail callers your
wack pack basically
yeah basically um
so i'm gonna tease something and we're
gonna do it we're gonna do a little
challenge okay
i have a voicemail this is not a joke
okay
new caller his uh oh i think using the
gavel on my mic has loosened it
this is seriously the guy's name cletus
from mississippi
okay if you want to hear from cletus
from mississippi let's get to like
20 website members okay
we're at five right now and i'll even
count the additional three twitch subs
so we're out we're actually already at
eight cletus from mississippi
is something that is it's it's
it's gonna change the trajectory of this
program i think this new character
cletus from mississippi
so i'm gonna hold that back i'm not
going to play that right now but i will
we're just looking at 20. but i do have
a new voicemail from the manic moderate
which i will play for you right now
hey this is bob from lakeland florida
i'm back from
orlando down there where our little
buddy showed up yeah
what he's he he's gonna he's gonna see
you still going on about that
second party crap i told you it was
[ __ ]
but no you you kept buying
you can't listen like nonsense he going
nowhere
he wants to stick around and destroy
them now
he doesn't want to leave i've i like
this guy i just don't have any idea what
he's talking about
the party wants to stick around and
destroy them
anyway just like there is a report that
you know donald trump why donald trump
didn't join the
alt tech you know well i'm afraid if i
don't
join all tech i'm going to crash their
system now he's addicted to the
mainstream tech you know just like these
other [ __ ] want to sit there and cry
victim i'm sick of hearing it
i don't use facebook for that purpose i
don't even i have a facebook i
i closed my twitter down because i was
you guys taking notes on this only there
because of trump so
once he was gone i just shut it off you
know
because i think twitter's [ __ ]
120 characters [ __ ] that
it's isn't it 280 now 120. use face
facebook you know that i don't even use
i use alt
tech too that's how i found you
you know you wouldn't for the for a
library i wouldn't even know you existed
because it's quite an endorsement of
libraries
youtube never suggested you to me they
always suggested tyt
those clowns you know you know the
ally's joke this guy's on fire
version of uh yeah
they're not reporting misinformation but
they're they act like
alex jones you know like a bunch of
idiots
so i like you and sam better and
some other other people but yeah
they're back all hell was that man i'll
tell you there was a lot of people there
outside that place it was fun
a lot of them didn't wear a mask oh my
god
super spreader oh
this is this is bob here in lakeland
florida you'll have a good day now
you're here
i don't know i don't ever know what he's
talking about
but it's compelling it's very very
compelling
a big thank you to brian little who has
just signed up at joinpakman.com getting
us to nine
also thanks to mint chips and five
gifted subs from ky
dizzle that's an additional six via
twitch putting us at 15.
all right just to show you that cletus
from uh where is it
cletus from mississippi is real i said
we would play cletus at 20.
here's just the first five seconds of
cletus just so you know
it's real take a listen harry david this
is cletus from mississippi
okay it's real it's completely and
totally real
cletus from mississippi listen again
uh-oh what the heck is going on here
david this is cletus from mississippi
all right
so we do have a cletus from mississippi
uh
voicemail and it's something i'm looking
looking looking very strongly at playing
okay a few other super chats daniel says
if i don't get to hear cletus i will
boycott
david my ears hurt from that horrible
display of the national anthem that
voice could break glass
i wonder what american idol judge would
say to her
david what's your opinion on the plan b
for 15 dollar minimum wage aka tax on
fortune 1000
companies i uh may be discussing that
tomorrow on the show
and uh this user says have you heard
circle back
wtf bra youtube
i have not i have not
uh maybe that's something i will look at
uh pretty soon at some point um
and we're going to have a report on uh
by by the way we also have a very
long segment today on the bonus show
about the new wealth tax proposed by
elizabeth warren and bernie sanders
which is slightly different
slightly different than the original one
uh but still interesting nonetheless
okay oh one more thing
oh wait people people are saying we got
to
oh i guess we did we i guess we did
because of astro lycos as gifts we are
at now 20 so i'll play the cleatest
voicemail
all right this is a new character this
is cletus from mississippi tell me what
you make of it
all right david this is cletus from
mississippi uh
been hearing a lot about these uh cues
and the anons and whatnot and
i just want to let uh all your viewers
out there now
uh if you are ever
told by one of your drinking buddies
that you got
that they got some sort of inside
knowledge that they know
something going on you don't know well
first off once they start telling you
weird [ __ ]
you say well you know
well jethro who is this benefit
who is who's making the money
follow the money essentially this is a
pretty base to actually analysis
who's getting a scribbler so to say and
uh
you know if there's nobody benefiting
nobody getting money nobody getting
skrilla
then you know your uh your
conspiracy theory might be kind of dumb
the
second litmus test yeah your conspiracy
theory
cletus is pretty pretty with it i'm not
gonna lie it is
how many goddang people is it gonna take
to keep this under wraps
like holy hell the whole moon landing
thing
that's uh that's a real question when it
comes to conspiracies how many people
would need to be involved and silent for
this to work my god you got
the scope you know you need that
the scope of how that could get done
is bigger than the scope that the damn
hubble telescope they put up in the sky
can see in the first goddamn place right
guys i have to tell you i can't find
anything to disagree with cletus from
mississippi on i think cletus from
mississippi is one of the most informed
and didactic
uh of callers we've had i think cletus
is great keeping it very real
and you know when i said we have a
cletus from mississippi i didn't say the
guy
didn't know what he was talking about
you all assumed
you assumed i just said cletus from
mississippi that's all
and uh i was i was very pleasantly
surprised by what he had to say
all right very good john hein or gary
della batte for stump the buoy
i don't know depends on the the subject
matter
what do you think about kovacsen indian
vaccine
i don't know enough about it to be able
to say much
i really wouldn't be able to say uh too
too much about it
generally speaking the vaccines so far
are
extraordinarily good at preventing
serious covet and death and that's what
we want
hey have you guys um if you've not
turned out
turned on fox news lately you might not
know
that they are essentially the dr seuss
channel now
if you follow aaron rupar on twitter uh
oh wait this i have to see lauren bover
makes up the word
transvex hikes is that like a tax hike
let's listen to this we can't say the
same for the so-called equality act
which we all know uh that that's just
the democrats uh using a play on words
there's nothing about
equality in that act if anything um it's
it's the um it's
it's supremacy of uh of of gays and and
lesbians and
and uh trans excites i mean like that's
what this is about is
transvex hikes oh my god i've got to
hear that one more time that's gold
and uh transvex i mean like that
how many x's are in that word
transvex hikes that's what this is about
it's about putting them
higher than anyone else it's not about
equality if you look at the
it's transvex hike supremacy um
okay but anyway the point is fox news is
now
all dr seuss all the time for dr seuss
universal orlando reportedly evaluating
their
seuss landing attraction which looks
like a lot of fun
the company says spectrum news is also
pulling six books off its shelves
so there is there's that uh cancel
culture commotion big explosive story
on fox news um let's see
here's another one from vice president
kamala harris
praised dr seuss and now it has
resurfaced because you know tweets never
go away
it was a twenty-second wow explosive
kamala harris story
white house dodges questions on why
dr seuss was snubbed
disinviting dr seuss
okay um let's see
other dr seuss segments cycle
of cancel culture and to think that i
saw it on mulberry street
taking a hit um here's pete
seth at a bar six dr
seuss books will no this is all day all
day
all day all day hannity covering it
yesterday
um obama in 2015
praising dr seuss oh my god
how will this ever how will we ever live
it down here's something about
potato hot go with mr and mrs potato
head going
gender neutral and
here's another hannity dr seuss
exclusive
on beyond zebra reportedly
printed on gender neutral paper
explosive story tonight at 10. so that
basically uh it's just dr seuss all day
every day at this point
all day every day um
okay very good so we got this dr seuss
material
out of the way massive dumps of cletus
knowledge
sin su says it's unlikely because of his
age but theoretically if trump runs and
wins in 24
would he be eligible to run again in 24
since it would not be three consecutive
terms what
do you mean 28 no he wouldn't if trump
runs and wins in 24 that's it that's his
second term no more
we can't even implement universal health
care our government simply is not that
organized to pull off all of these
conspiracies
very well said very well said yeah one
of one of the
fundamental inconsistencies from the
right-wing conspiracy theories
that involve the government is that the
same government that's way too
incompetent to even handle mail
um has pulled off some some completely
mind-blowing conspiracy theory
involving who knows how many different
elements uh okay we are live
let's see uh oh we'll stick with the
white house coverage it's often a little
bit a few seconds behind but
it's uh i tend to think of it as higher
quality coverage
i do want to say thank you to um
mk aviators and a couple other people
three three twitch subs dropped in there
out of nowhere appreciate that
um
kind of weird that it's live but the
white house coverage hasn't even started
yet that's weird
maybe we'll just go over here for now
atrocious because there is audio
one in this country who has done more
for women and children than speaker
nancy
pelosi the children the children
how many times have i heard that in my
first two years
in congress and now as we see the
promise
of working with president biden's
administration i don't think this is the
event that was promoted
president biden there's no one more
prepared to help
usher through our agenda there's a woman
who has built a reputation
as an unrivaled negotiator and
legislative tactician
the woman responsible for guiding the
passage
of landmark bills like the affordable
care act the american recovery
act and soon the american rescue plan
at a time when this country are plotting
to undermine the right to vote she's
ensuring that house democrats
protect americans voices at the ballot
box
since the day she arrived in congress
speaker pelosi has been a
tireless champion what is this and on a
personal note
my wife cheryl and i and our four sons
are grateful colleagues it is my great
honor
to welcome the most accomplished and
effective
legislator of our lifetimes speaker
nancy pelosi thank you so much i'm so
honored by your introduction
this is a very special evening for me my
colleagues
white house still not live introducing
for the very first time
joe biden as president of the united
states
and i couldn't my heart could not be
filled with more joy to have
uh that occasion mark by introducing him
to our house democratic caucus that joy
is also also okay increased by
being introduced by angie craig and i'm
so glad she referenced
oh my god now this has started hold on
whom i love hearing about
and now in front of the president of the
united states
thank you angie for your leadership your
friendship and your very generous
introduction you make this evening very
special to me
a special evening first time mr
president that i'm introducing you as
president of the united states to my
great house democratic caucus
that makes it even better my colleagues
as you know our nation is blessed
with joe biden as president of the
united states i hope they're going to
talk about covet relief
president he knows how to get the job
done
when our nation faced the great
recession it was joe biden
who led the implementation and
accountability of ara
helping to create and save millions of
jobs
that experience served sims well with
the american rescue plan
when the democratic caucus was passing
the affordable care act joe biden was a
partner for progress
in the white house and that experience
serves him well
as we face the coronavirus crisis joe
biden has been a voice of reason
and resilience with a clear path to lead
us
out of this crisis
on another front i want to tell you
about joe biden
of joe biden i've seen with parents the
victims of gun violence
listening to them and offering them the
empathy grace and courage
that he can give them as someone with
the terrible understanding of a father
who has shared their
experience continuing on the family
franco and jill biden
have taken their experience as a blue
star family
to help ensure that service members
military families
and veterans have their service
respected the support that they need and
the benefits
they have earned he is our
commander-in-chief
and joe biden is the first president in
40 years
to have a son who served in a war he
knows
what it is like for military families of
those who are deployed
he knows the role that our hidden heroes
and caregivers have
for returning veterans and he's so proud
i genuinely don't know what's going on
but let's just figure it out together
who have suffered from cancer
men are at many after being exposed to
toxins in the burn pits of iraq
there's just one reason for his
enthusiasm for the cancer moonshot
demonstrated as recently as today my
bipartisan meeting
on cancer at the white house i've seen
president biden working behind the
scenes
hammering out solutions for the american
people
he is a leader with the humility to seek
expertise
and science and the confidence to act
upon it
on the policy side president biden has
been a long time legislative partner
including for bawwa for gun violence
prevention
and of course with his connection to
america's
working families on the global front
president biden is a distinguished world
leader who commands the respect of
allies and adversaries alike especially
personally enjoyed seeing as a catholic
i enjoyed seeing them received at the
vatican
when the pope was inaugurated it was all
a little weird it's inaugurated
on the political front joe biden has
campaigned with or
for many members of congress almost
everyone in this virtual setting
thank you mr president for being there
and for with us
and for us my husband paul always says i
just wonder how long into a speech it
will be before nancy starts talking
about
her grandchildren our grandchildren my
grandchildren
have for many many years been long time
friends of joe biden
they have a range in age but
all of them love joe biden but let me
tell you one story
i think with like 2013
four and five-year-old two of my paul
and thomas
uh we were at an event the g-triple-c in
new york and joe biden
was the futurist speaker they were so
excited
to see him because they'd heard so much
about him from their cousins
and they met him they talked about pets
and things like that
and afterward after the luncheon was
over i took them
for candy don't tell their mom i took
them for candy
at a place dylan's in new york well they
have sort of like swinging doors
you have to get through the doors from
one part of the store to the next
so here they are pace is packed and jam
these kids are making all this noise
over there on the side
and all of a sudden i hear them
pronounce
in order to open these doors we do not
say
open sesame we say open
biden that's our magic word
open biden i love it
now more than ever we need a
battle-tested forward-looking leader
who will fight for the people a
president with the values experience and
the strategic thinking
to bring our nation together and to
build a better fairer world
for our children as president he is
taking us to new heights of inclusion
in the success of america president
biden is a leader
who was the personification of hope and
courage
values authenticity and integrity
joe biden is president as president and
with democratic majorities in the house
and senate
we will deliver bold progress for the
people
and now it is my privilege to present
the 45th president of the united states
as my children grandchildren would say
open biden mr president
nancy i love you there's no one i'd
rather work with than you we've been
friends a long time
and your whole family your daughters and
it has just been
a great relationship and i think that
uh angie was absolutely correct
that you've been the consummate leader
i've been here a long time and there's
been no speaker
that's been your equal although been
some great speakers
and you just have a special way about
you nancy
and you're also very very which is
important
you're kind but you're tough and you
know what's right and you stick by it
and uh i admire the devil out of you and
uh i uh i i want to thank uh
somebody i campaigned for he was leading
by 30 points till i campaigned for him
but he still won anyway
hakeem jeffries and vice chair that's
actually not bad
aguilar for putting this conference
together and including me
and i want to thank the entire
leadership team and all your committee
chairs
for taking an important uh step in the
american rescue plan last week
he all showed yeah where is that time
when the american people are depending
on us
and they are desperately in need of us
that a diverse caucus isn't a divided
caucus
congressman clyburn i also want to note
that it was almost
exactly a year ago today
that you delivered the endorsement to me
in south carolina it meant so much
to me in my campaign you're a great
friend on the night of the
of that primary america had uh
confirmed only fewer than 100
coveted cases that's just a year ago
brianna taylor and george floyd were
still alive
california had yet to suffer the worst
the war of what would become the worst
fire season in recorded history and
there have been no violent insurrection
on the capitol hill
and uh i could go on a lot's changed
my point is this in the year that has
passed
all the challenge i spoke about that
night
jobs and economy affordable accessible
health care
climate change and the need to root out
institutional racism
the need for unity and healing have all
become
urgent urgent urgent urgent
urgent especially in light of the
pandemic that has taken the lies over as
of yesterday
518
720 i believe it was
americans fellow americans have lost
their lives
and more than 400 000
businesses mostly small businesses many
minority businesses
have been shuttered cost to millions of
jobs 1.3
million public sector education nurses
cops
firefighters essential workers have lost
their jobs
so my message today is really simple you
you this caucus have shown the american
people the difference between
democratic leadership and what we just
had
leadership makes a difference and you're
continuing to do so
for example i know that this week you're
working on the
protect our democracy reforms as well as
the george floyd justice and policing
act
both of which i strongly support and i
know the past couple of days
you've had briefings and conversations
on immigration health care foreign
policy
climate crisis and a lot more and as you
work on all of these
i urge you to continue to speak up and
speak out
about the american rescue plan and
here's why
you know the confidence in the american
and american government has
has been plummeting since the late 60s
to what it is now and many remember that
in 2009
we expended a lot of political capital
nancy and i and others
in the recovery act it was it was an act
that had less than two tenths of one
percent waste or fraud in it
according to the experts and the
economist told us we literally so
clearly we are not
going to get debate or discussion of
what's the disaster is happening with
the coveted relief bill so we're going
to keep monitoring this
i want to check in with our good friend
briefly stephen kenneth destiny bonnell
ii because there are
there are things going on that i want to
get caught up on with him
um stephen are you with us argentinian
friend what's up how you doing hey how
are you good stephen kenneth destiny
bonnell arguably the most well-known
cuban-american streamer
um on on twitch i think is fair to say
right
i think that's just undeniable of this
yeah of course listen
prevalent cuban american political
streamers on this platform that also
play minecraft in factorio yeah
i heard and correct me if i'm wrong
that something ugly is happening with
the entire omaha
activism that you're involved in yeah a
lot of people are
writing a lot of them hit pieces david
that's how it goes
is explain what's happening is it that
you made some vile comments at some
point in the past and now they're coming
back to bite the guy you're supporting
in omaha for mayor is that right
yeah basically oh and and the comments
were what inciting violence
um it was over the kenosha stuff to make
it sound basically people trying to make
it sound like i don't like blm or
black lives matter or like protest or
anything and do you like protests
yeah of course one of the few positions
that i radically have supported over the
past like five years or 10 years even
so do you fee i mean i think the good
thing is that remind me the name of the
candidate you're supporting there
um well it was mark guggel in omaha are
you no longer involved because it looked
like he
that he was saying that just because you
said something
you know a while ago that doesn't mean
that the movement is bad
yeah i mean that was initially what he
tried to play but there's like a ton of
pressure from
there's a lot of other campaigns that
are trying to pressure uh
him to like drop the race basically so
wait a second
it's not that they want him to denounce
you they want him to just quit
because you're supporting him well
people are saying that he should get in
line behind
the other candidates in the uh in the
race uh
what does that even mean i don't even
understand that what does that mean to
drop
your campaign and get behind other
candidates what do you mean oh oh get
but i thought you meant like get in line
behind like wait for someone else to be
made
i might have misspoken wow that i'm so
sorry to hear that it's gotten very ugly
now do you think that maybe
you could have couched your comments in
a different way and and this never would
have happened
or do you think that it's literally just
a hit job
are you asking me if i could go back in
time and change words that i've said so
that people don't
i don't i don't know how i'm supposed to
answer that that's exactly well you
might say
hell no i said it exactly the way i
wanted to say it and i wouldn't change
it or you might say
yeah no it came off the wrong way i
would have said it differently
um i mean i can do my best but i mean i
do i've probably done over 30 thousands
of hours of content in my life you want
to clip 16 seconds out of any 20 or 30
minute discussion
you can probably make me sound like i
say almost anything so wow um
yeah man so what's are you basically are
you
pulling back from from organizing for
now um yeah for a little bit i'll just
play video games i guess join the rest
of you guys on the internet that just
talk about politics instead of doing
anything about it you know
what's more interesting playing video
games or helping mayors
um i feel like real life activism is
more interesting
but um nobody really likes to do it
because you don't make any money doing
it you get a lot more money posting
videos and talking about [ __ ] right
it seems for you the real world activism
has actually made you lose money if we
go back to that scam fiasco from the
last time
well any real-life activism is going to
be a loser in money because it's
expensive
and time-consuming yeah yeah yeah yeah
wow
i don't even i'm just trying to take it
all in and understand it all that's
that's that's horrible
like without defending anything you said
and i don't know what you said it's just
too bad that this happened
um yeah well you know it's all part of
the game it's all part of
what we do right do you think that
like is the outrage
genuine or do you think it's just
cynical and trying to hurt the candidate
without really anybody being truly
outraged
i don't think very many people involved
in politics period are very genuine i
don't think very many people give a [ __ ]
about most of the issues i think it's
just a way to kind of like show your
other friends like how cool you are how
hip you are
it's kind of like liking a sports team
or having like a favorite artist that
you don't listen to any of the songs or
albums they put out
wow wow um
all right well that i mean that's
definitely a downer i'm
sorry to hear that that's going on has
uh
i know that actually hold on on that
note maybe i'll bully you a little bit
what's your take on the 15 hour minimum
wage thing
please don't tell me you're part of the
crowd of dumb [ __ ] that thinks that
biden is unilaterally destroying our 15
hour minimum wage
no no i don't i don't think that i don't
think that although i
well when we're watching an event that
seems to have just gone south
um i m i i do think that just saying
oh it's the parliamentarian and that's
it it's kind of silly
alternatives it's clear that the you
know
but biden is not committed to forcing it
into covet relief
and i predicted that before he was even
sworn in so like i'm not surprised by
any of it
okay there's like there is no
alternative right you understand that
right or do you tell people that or do
you think
or do you pretend that there is
something that biden or harris could
have done here
harris can can uh try to overrule the
parliamentarian and then it has to be
voted on
and then let's say for instance
hypothetically let's say that they do
manage to do that yeah what do you think
happens next
you're saying you include you include 15
in the bill
and then then they vote on the bill yeah
then what happens
i think joe manchin votes i think joe
manchin votes against it so we're
delayed on our
coveted relief fund of 1.9 trillion
dollars and then we have to go back to
the drawing board on the entire bill
yeah i don't disagree with you
gotcha yeah okay the the the talking
points around all of it are so cancerous
and so [ __ ] stupid
and then people's oh wait am i allowed
to see the effort on here
you're allowed to say it yeah i mean
it's like do we like it as a different
question but
gotcha um yeah it's just been really
frustrating watching a lot of the
cancers dialogue around
this that somehow biden or harris could
have unilaterally gotten a 15 hour
minimum wage and the fact that they
weren't willing to try to overrule the
parliamentarian when it doesn't even
mean it would have passed in a bill
yeah would have delayed all of our
relief that that makes it so that biden
doesn't support a 15 hour minimum wage
is crazy to me
no i don't disagree i understand yeah
and then you're getting all these people
that are like well the thing is
we just need to get rid of we need to
get rid of mansion we need to get rid of
some of these more moderate debts like
how about you pick up more seats you
worthless
[ __ ] like why not actually get more
democrats in the senate instead of
trying to like viciously purity test the
50 seats that you're barely [ __ ]
holding like right
i mean i think what some people i mean
our stuff is so horrible what maybe so
by the way are you streaming now
yeah i am oh you are i think one of the
things maybe that's not
being discussed enough is like if
mansion were bernie he wouldn't be a
senator in west virginia
and so so you know yeah that's why
people
people like they already tried to run a
progressive in west virginia they got
destroyed they got obliterated you know
there's a reason why the justice stems
you know supported like one-seventh as
many candidates in you know 2018 as they
did in 2016. there's a reason why these
ultra-progressive people only win in
like the bluest places in the us you
know
just knowing that they're critical of
moderate damage while sitting in the
safest plus 40 districts imaginable
it's so near annoying to me ugh who are
you most mad at right now
and anybody that's trying to blame biden
or harris and being ineffective leaders
the problem is that we just we don't
have enough seats in the senate to do
what we want to do
i'm just upset at people who don't
understand how our political system
works it's like it's incredibly
annoying
wow wow hope for the best i'll see what
happens
how uh any any what's the plan for now
just
you're gonna stay around home base and
stream for the foreseeable future
yeah why not play video games it sounds
like a fun time
is um is molina destiny banel still in
europe
um yeah she'll be there for a few more
weeks i think weeks okay
okay uh wow wow yeah
so are you you're not like i guess
you're not super optimistic about the
next six months it sounds like
for in regards to biden or american
politics yeah yeah
no american politics is a horrible
[ __ ] [ __ ] show where like
we were on the precipice of this like
amazing coalition in
the left that we could have built um
especially with the republican party
potentially falling into complete
disaster
um how many unregistered um from the
republican party after the capital riots
right
but now you've got like this growing
faction of delusional lefties that don't
know how government works
like just making these crazy demands
like that just betray a total
misunderstanding of how any part of our
government functions
and um i hope i just i hope that that i
hope that that growing cancer in the
party can get radiation out
soon or they can figure out a way to
kind of bring themselves more in line
because jesus
it would be so sad to see like the
opportunity that we have to like make
actual real material change in this
country
completely squandered because a bunch of
purity testers that live in white
suburbs from
from plus 40 districts are you know
decide to make twitter the new
playground for politics
hey what um as a as a cuban-american
streamer
where are you on latinx
i don't i try to follow the new the new
white people sayings on twitter i don't
the latinx [ __ ] is
cringe i don't yeah i'm against it i've
come out against this thing yeah it's
all like
super ultra cringe yeah as uh as someone
who is
um latino and hispanic and
an immigrant from argentina uh it just
doesn't make sense to me and in fact i i
told the story on the bonus show today
um about uh when i was like
i was hosting these latino media awards
and in the script they sent me it said
latinx and i said
listen guys my audience knows i'm not
for this
if i now read latinx i'm not gonna be
nobody's gonna be happy if i'm reading
latinx and i was like prepared for a
fight
and they said oh yeah just say latino
it's fine that's oh good not a fight
no you wanna here's like a hot
prediction that i have for 2022
okay maybe 2024. and i hope people laugh
at me and say you were so wrong on this
um i think that we're going to see
increasingly i think we're going gonna
see more and more
uh persons of color in this country
especially hispanic people been towards
the republican party
hmm why do you think that something that
i've said for a long time
is that if republicans could just for
two seconds
stop being racist they would realize
that they share so many conservative
values among
hispanic and black communities right
that yeah they just they would and
anybody that
i know that like for a lot of white
people um in on twitch they're gonna get
really mad when they hear that but like
a lot of
like um a lot of like minority
communities their social values tend to
be quite a bit more conservative than
like the very progressive white
younger people in the united states and
if republicans could just put that aside
for a moment
i think that they would have a really
large base there and we saw in the last
election
that there were huge large communities
uh brown people that were getting super
turned off by a lot of the more extreme
lefty rhetoric especially the acap stuff
and especially the socialism stuff that
were starting to bend more and more
towards the republican party oh yeah i
know there were there i mean there's a
with in
the so you're making an overall analysis
and it's completely accurate when you
start slicing and dicing different
communities
the reasons why are very different like
the reasons why you saw massive dumps of
cuban-american florida votes go
to trump relative to the previous
election has more to do with like fears
of socialism
whereas the reason that sometimes you'll
have uh
black voters vote for republicans often
has
more to do with with like religious and
social conservatives it's it's all
different reasons but the
the end the end result is the same yeah
i think that it's important to realize
that like i've said it so much that it
sounds like a meme coming for me so i
maybe doesn't carry as much weight but
when you run around screaming
like get rid of all the police a cab
a-cap a-cab billionaires are evil get
rid of the plea blah blah blah
socialism is the best like this is a
very very this is like one of the
like you can light up a room with your
whiteness when you run around screaming
this stuff like
you like there are no black communities
of voters in the united states that are
all like oh yeah like get rid of the
police we want all the police
like these don't exist and you know like
a lot of hispanic people that come from
south america are not too
hip on socialism they don't have like
the best taste of that their mouths even
though for some reason a lot of young
white people like to pretend that that's
the case so everyone right i mean i
think the problem
the problem with the socialism thing is
like there's no there's
socialism doesn't have any political
power in the united states so it's
fear-mongering about socialism it's not
real socialism that anybody's rejecting
well i mean there are people that are
coming from south america that
have either been like people from
venezuela or have heard about venezuela
that aren't going to have the best
impressions of socialism you know you've
got a lot of older people the centers of
cubans that don't have
good memories of what it was like living
under castro yes but there are
also tons of people including from
argentina
bolivia and other places that aren't
against
their version of sort of socialism
light and and they see it very
differently so the socialism
fear-mongering works only on certain
groups for a reason
for sure yeah i'd be curious though like
how many brown immigrants
and it might be a lot actually i don't
know how many brown immigrants in the
united states
are all the way from are from argentina
well argentina is almost completely
white so very few
very very few yeah so like i am i know i
know i i know like uh
i know one guy named matthias who i
think would be what we would consider a
non-white argentinian
um who actually was a police officer in
argentina
uh but no argentina is overwhelmingly
white yeah
do you consider yourself a person of
color
um i was when i applied for financial
aid for school but okay otherwise
the reason i ask is there's this thing
have you seen the show the queen's
gambit
um no but i've heard a lot about it okay
so the lead actress anya taylor joy
is a fellow argentinian and there was
recently a write-up
i don't know what award she won but the
write-up said she's the first woman of
color to win the award and i was like
well if she's a woman of color i'm a man
of color
it doesn't really what's his name anya
anya taylor joy
now the thing is it's not about looking
to see if she looks white to you because
you know it is about it is about looking
to see if they look white but i think
the point is like mike's
i'm latino and hispanic but my
experience in the united states has not
been of one
one of a person of color yeah exactly
that's why like people
i i honest to god i hate talking about
race issues now because honest to god
everybody is so
clueless i don't know if anybody knows
anything about racism they've all become
like virtue signal points but um
like for for the older people that
remember these conversations and how
they go
how you look is like one of the most
defining aspects of your race because it
determines how other people in society
treat it determines your experience yep
yeah because of like for me like i'm
half cuban but my experience in america
is that of like a white male that's the
experience that i have like i might be
half hispanic but that's not
like you know i i wasn't raised in a
hispanic community i don't have people
that discriminate me
up based on what i look or where they
think i come from like yeah that
appearance aspect is incredibly
important to your
relationship with race yeah i i totally
totally agree but in any case
i think based on uh if she's a person of
color i'm a person of color and i don't
think i
am in terms of describing my experience
so it's just kind of a funny thing to
see and
also it's like i don't know that it's
it's that relevant but um
it was just an unusual thing to see
uh all right what else did i have on my
agenda to go over with you
um any any pro are you having any
problems with any particular
online righties like i'm so out of the
space i know at one point there was
someone
uh bastiat does that ring a bell to you
yeah he's like um kind of like maybe
like neoliberal
i don't know i wouldn't consider him
conservative oh he's not concerned okay
yeah see i'm just so
out i just don't know what's what um
what's going like is
are you are you beefing with anybody i
guess is the question
unfortunately it's all just [ __ ]
lefties like all the conservatives have
been banned from everywhere
like we've tried so hard to remove them
from literally every [ __ ] platform
that there's nothing left except a bunch
of like cringy white tankies like that's
the only like extreme people that exist
online anymore
well really but i mean it looks like
some of the like the top the top
literally the top person on facebook is
ben shapiro
yeah but the the only conservatives left
are the ones that won't engage with
anybody so stephen crowder is popular
too
but right that guy won't ever engage
with anybody right crowd or shapiro like
they just have their own little circle
tricks even yeah yeah yeah they bring on
like adversarial people only he'll
yeah i don't know if you know that do
you know this guy dan bongino
well i feel like i recognize the name
yeah he's he's big on facebook also i
don't know that he like debates people
though
huh i need to start streaming on
facebook that's the next thing i do to
set up my tri stream yeah
um what was oh here's something that's
like blown my mind too that's also like
you know what i don't have like an
experience of racism against me
the only time it's happened actually is
with left-leaning communities
um is there an argentinian equivalent to
the to the word gusano
you ever heard that before yeah i think
gusano which literally means
worm is is it meant for
white south americans who are
conservative or something like that i
don't even know i don't know what it
means so
when i argue with people only with
lefties by the way
it's so weird to me that the only time
i've experienced like racial hatred is
from left
only with leftovers as soon as somebody
finds out that my
half of my mom's family or half of half
of my family from my mom's side was from
cuba people start calling me a gusano
saying that my ancestors owned slaves
which to my knowledge is not true i've
never heard that i've never seen that on
my phone but yeah it's something that
and then the crazy thing is like people
will trip up so hard
large content creators will come out the
central committee might be
like all these people come out uh hassan
and his community and they will defend
like oh gusano that's not a slur
they're just describing your political
positions even though i'm like
but it's a term only applied to white to
people who are of cuban descent like
yeah or i thought i thought it was that
latin i thought it was latin american of
any kind i didn't know it was
i've heard some people say that there
are different words or terms at least
for other countries too but
the more specific one that i'm familiar
with is cuba but yeah yeah holy [ __ ]
it's like so weird
that i can't like to see so many people
like try to defend so yeah so i've had
like um
there was this one guy that was
screaming me in his twitch and it just
it blows my mind because i feel like i'm
living in some
sargon of akkad alternate reality hey
that's
now that's a name i haven't heard in
years is is he still around does he
still have
his platforms i think he does his thing
on youtube but i don't know i don't see
much
he's gone like farther and farther right
though yeah that guy was like
i forgot completely about him i i've not
come across
even accidentally i mean i browse
youtube on a personal channel where
anytime i see political recommendations
i i say don't recommend this channel so
i might have just said
don't show me this nonsense years ago
but i've not even casually come across
him anymore yeah that's interesting yeah
i mean listen the the slave ownership
thing i don't have to worry about my
family is
jews that went to argentina only when
slavery was already done
so that one i don't have to worry i
agree
geez yeah um interesting okay so you're
not you're mostly beefing with lefties
and where are you on uh where are you on
vaccination
um are you asking if i've gotten
vaccinated yet yeah
um i thought about it i found out that
there's a clinic
near here that like you can just lie and
say that if you work in some healthcare
industry they won't check your id and
they'll vaccinate you
yeah but i feel like it's a little bit
unethical because i just sit in my house
all day so i'll probably just wait until
the official signups roll through
that seems fair yeah i ended up getting
like a trash vaccine that was going to
get thrown out
but um i mean the uh
the the delivery is happening
dramatically much and much much faster i
i like the way it's going personally i
don't know
yeah between the infection rates and
then the actual vaccinations like it's
looking like by summer
we're going to hit that like herd
immunity which is pretty unbelievable
yeah
now do you follow like oh are the
variants going to be
are you following kovid that closely at
this point my understanding is that all
of the variants use the same spike
protein to bind onto your cells and as
long as that's the case the vaccine
should remain effective that's my
understanding thus far
yeah yeah it seems like they they will
be slightly less effective
um particularly against the south
african variant but the effectiveness
for preventing death in sirius covid is
like
close to 99 yeah which is awesome
yeah and are you planning on travel
after vaccination you've been traveling
anyway i guess
um yeah a little bit i try to remain
responsible but i've traveled for my um
canvassing events and everything so
yeah very nice well
i mean listen i i it sounds like you do
sound
despondent to some degree i'm a little
worried like there's a bit of
despondency coming through
it doesn't feel like you're in a great
place but online politics is just so
such a blight on the world yeah i don't
know
i i almost see did you see i i know that
you'll never call these people did you
see kolinsky's video on that mega church
guy
no jesus this guy so this guy basically
gets up
on tv and he's like i'm so upset
that they're trying to censor our
religion trying to take our first
amendment rights
we need to get these we need to get
these big tech companies that are
censoring all of our churches
i covered that i covered that today yeah
rick wiles that's the guy who warned
about a jew coup against donald trump
you should see kolinsky's take on that
it's why what what did he say
he basically spends the entire like 10
minutes worshiping the guy like this
guy's so left i can't believe it he
wants to take money away from
millionaire
it's legitimately one of the dumbest
pieces of media that i've ever seen in
my life
oh my god my take on that
my take on that was it's the
prototypical example
of how the populist sounding rhetoric
will lead you
into an insane place it's like when
tucker
if you don't know anything about tucker
carlson i know too much and i know other
people that fall for the same trap yes
right as soon as dr carlson is like
corporations are destroying america all
of these lefties on my twitter feed will
be like oh my god carlson
based how does even he know how basic he
is like oh my god it's like are you
serious
yeah and then like he'll and then he'll
say and the solution is like we've got
to stop the brown people from mexico who
are going to make the country dirty from
coming in and then like whoa whoa whoa i
thought this guy was left to some
yeah my take on the rick wiles thing was
um
he doesn't like the uh sort of like
openness that's happening culturally in
the united states
by the way all the ceos i i i'm trying
to remember the list of ceos he listed
but they were like all are almost all
jewish of course yeah so so
for i saw i it to me it seemed very
transparently like nonsense i didn't see
kyle's clip on it i'll check it out
though
mm-hmm yeah how are you doing david
what's how's your how's your recovery do
you feel optimistic about how do you
feel biden's first hundred days are
gonna go
do you think it's going to be enough for
2022 what do you think i
i think it the it won't it won't decide
2022 one way or the other but i do think
that he's going to blow
a hundred million vaccines in a hundred
days out of the water i think we could
even get 200 or 225 million
yeah i feel the only thing that worries
me is
i feel like 2022 is everything because
we're already holding on to the senate
by a razor
margin or less than that and then we
lost seats in the house
i haven't looked at the map for who's up
who's at risk of losing more in 2022 but
man dude if we if we lose the majority
in the senate then biden is just
his presidency he's basically done for
the next two to six years if he wins
reelection still it's just going to be
like obama right
is there something that could happen
where you might just like remove
yourself from the online political space
all together and just be like i'm i'm
kind of
i'm just done now i'm only doing video
games or even retire from streaming
um i never quit streaming i enjoy
streaming i don't know man
online politics is exhausting but who
knows we'll see yeah
you know one thing that might be useful
and if this i mean like if a lot of your
you know engagement is based around this
it won't work but
i have basically cut myself off from
ninety percent of the online politics
world and mostly i'm
consuming stuff via via just reading and
so i feel like the downside is when
people call in and they go oh did you
see this that the it's like i don't even
know who these people are
it might limit my ability to comment but
i think it's far healthier
probably actually your mind is probably
much a much happier place than mine yeah
it's a sanctuary that's good
it doesn't sound like you're into the
idea though um
what can i say i live for the drama i
like fighting with people
hey last um last thing i haven't talked
to our friend
austin very much recently how is he
doing what's
what's his content look like lately i
haven't uh checked in with him for a bit
um i don't know if you're trying to get
in contact with him um
try to get a big stream going throw up
some minecraft and maybe you'll be on
one of his next shows
no no we we twitter dm every once in a
while it's just been a little bit since
i've been in touch with with him is he
uh he he's
has his show changed at all um i think
he kind of like rebranded to a lot more
kind of like family-friendly stuff
so he's focusing on that type of content
yeah interesting
family friendly austin that's compelling
yeah
all right well steven listen it all
sounds uh you've really said it all
i think is the way i would say it um you
and hassan okay now are still bad
um no no still bad the only way it will
ever be okay again is if i get way
bigger he gets way smaller so
that bums me out stepping stones to him
that really bums me out because we had
such a we had like a perfect dinner out
in l.a you know
we did he had a lot to gain from us back
then yeah that's not true
that's ridiculous what are you gonna do
you know i think that's that's crazy
that's a crazy
that's not why you went to dinner that's
insane oh yeah you don't think so
not not even for a second not even for
one second
okay i think he went for the uh for the
lamb sausages which were delicious
that's possible yeah you know what your
mind is a sanctuary david one day i want
to take a stroll through it it seems
like a
wonderful place a lot of flowers a lot
of vegetation in there
reading any interesting non-fiction or
fiction lately
any interesting non-fiction or fiction
lately um
you know not at this particular point in
time now hey have you ever read the book
thinking fast and slow
yes yes by daniel kahneman very good
book yeah do you think it's a good book
you like it
i do i mean it's a good it's a good just
overview of behavioral economics
okay interesting i have that i might uh
i might take it out
right now i'm actually reading a billion
dollar loser about the rise and fall of
wework
okay and then also i'm reading uh
travels with charlie by john steinbeck
wow wait do you read two different books
at the same time that that's the
nonfiction i'm reading then i'm also
reading some fiction
but like you do it at the same time you
don't finish one and then the other no
no
because i read non-fiction during the
day i don't find non-fiction relaxing at
night and then at night i'll read
fiction wait a second oh my goodness are
you the kind of person that when you
have food on your plate do you mix your
foods together
mix them in what way like if you have
like
say you've got like corn and like
potatoes and like green beans would you
just mix these all up into one bite and
just eat it like that or something
no i think there's certain dishes where
you might kind of comb
proportionally combine like let me give
you an example
uh let's say for breakfast you know i
scramble up an egg
and then saute a piece of turkey bacon
and then uh saute a little spinach and
have a piece of toast
right yeah that's fine of course i
probably would take little pieces of the
turkey bacon
and kind of proportionally combine them
with the scrambled egg to get kind of
like a mixed flavor bite
that's more than fair but my question is
deeper than that david
would you ever take a piece of that
turkey bacon that turkey sausage bacon
put it on your fork and then load that
fork up with some pancakes or waffle
and eat that together would you ever
notice those no no no no no there are
some rules you're not a complete and
total heathen i could respect that
that's
absolutely no i would never do that but
uh i mean at that
at a certain point it's like just blend
your food and drink it you know it's
like that we how far are we gonna go
with this
well i mean they're served separately
and they're meant to be enjoyed
separately i
i completely agree with you are somebody
that reads books different types of
books in the evening and the in the
night
or at the evening in the morning i think
you should appreciate that yeah reading
science when you're trying to fall
asleep doesn't make sense to me
okay all right all right stephen listen
it's
it's always a pleasure it's not clear if
my audience likes or hates you but i
know that you don't even care about that
that's the great thing about you
yeah well hey listen if any of your
audience hates me um and i've seen a few
of them out there that do it
the little proletariat that other guy
there's there's a couple of them
looking at him uh they can always hop on
my stream we can have a conversation for
five minutes
until they start crying and [ __ ] off so
if they want to uh have them hop on but
otherwise
david i love you it's been great
checking in with you you're one of my
favorite correspondents here
on the dgg analyst desk uh we really
appreciate checking in with our local uh
persons of color so
thanks a lot for hopping in and giving
us your take on the launch all right
there it is
cuban american streamer stephen kenneth
destiny bennell ii we'll talk to you
soon okay
all right have fun all right there it is
uh a lot a lot going on
uh steven not in great spirits not in
great spirits
but um i worry about him i really do
i really do all right guys thanks for
joining me the joe biden event was
bizarre and extremely oh let's listen to
what's happening let's see what they're
saying
i'm a person of color
problem
what about you dan how far remember
you're from mexico
dan's jewish so yo yo soy mucho
as long as they haven't done the
purification process he could still be
mixed depending on
oh jeez it's getting it's it took a turn
for the worse there very very quickly
um all right guys thank you for joining
me i'm gonna be back very soon with
stories of
uh books and vaccinations and various
food items and that type of thing all
right see everybody very soon oh let's
raid someone on twitch
let's see who we've got that we can even
raid
i don't even know uh i'm not and nobody
i'm following is likely to acknowledge
me
um all right let's raid hikaru
nakamura let's do it join me for a raid
and then we'll see everybody back here
before you know it i'll be streaming
again
you